ouais je vous poser une autre question
mais serge j'aimerais qu'on change un
peu la lumière là gilbert collard ça
risque quand vous dites gilbert collard
qu'on vous dit
onana qu'on vous dit gilbert collard
quand vous le dis on ne peut plus rien
on ne m'aime pas et je le sais est ce
que finalement votre problème dans la
vie ça serait pas d'être aimée tout
simplement je crois que le problème de
tous les êtres humains c'est de n'être
pas assez aimée oui oui oui je le
confesse volontiers oui
donc c'est pour ça vous êtes comme ça
peut-être peut-être vous êtes sincère là
ça fait vite la vérité la vraie on
rallume
ça rappelle un peu la moue trois mois
s'ils n'ont rien n'exagérons rien des
coups durs il a alors comme votre livre
vous dites que c'est un coup de gueule